nicht in den himmel schauen de sterne
ich bin blau was herzlich willkommen
meine lieben freunde zu dem sowohl aus
zudem wohl am meisten gewünschten
nachgefragten video zur zeit und zwar
böse kommentare lesen teil 3 ich würde
sagen ich gar nicht lange um heißen brei
herum die erste folge war megalan
pompöse kommentare lesen die zweite war
richtig kurz das heißt ich werde jetzt
versuchen lebensmittel ding zu schaffen
was wir wahrscheinlich wieder nicht
gelingen wird übrigens richtig hier die
hier
hier kriegt er die kommentare jetzt
eingeblendet das habe ich mir gedacht
ist eine coole idee weil sodann mit und
wir fangen an
wir starten direkt richtig niveauvoll
der user mit dem namen conny ist scheiße
schreibt conny do you speak geburt pure
hoher auf mit youtube ist nicht so dumm
wie du.de wurde also keiner ist auf ihn
eingegangen und dann schreibt er selber
sich eine antwort will keine
kinderwunsch und 7
dann schreibt morys holzsteg drunter ich
bin nie älter als du
ich bin schon ein
ich bin schon ein scharfes s 8 vettel
ich weiß das ganze so ein bisschen mit
ironie verbunden aber dieser dass er
sich sogar seinen namen sogar zu conny
ist scheiße so ändert ist schon richtig
stark ach so ich hab auch noch das
wunder geschrieben hier werden ostsee
[Musik]
youtube auf
ich bin am überlegen ob ich da jetzt
lachen sollte oder eigentlich weinen
sollte weil wir wirklich lasst uns
einfach mal so im raum steht übrigens
allgemeinen letzter zeit mein sehr viele
leute so ja ich schreibe einfach irgend
einen negativen kommentar und dann komme
ich in die folge wie beispielsweise der
aig ich bin böse bin ich nun in folge
nummer drei
so einfach ist es nämlich nicht wissen
auch sehr nice wollen anderer typ
versucht hatte ein video zu kommen stv
praise and more böser kommentar 89 likes
so einfach kann es gehen einfach böse
sein und ihr kriegt leichtes todes so
und ich will ohne spaß mehr nach dem
ersten und zweiten videowand halt finde
ich so oft irgendwelche kommentare bei
mir unter den videos kommen wir erzählen
eine geschichte ich fange an
davon gibt es jetzt die kommentare
wurden videos also wenn ihr wenn ich
jetzt unter dem video wenn jeder ein
böser kommentare unterschreibt dann bin
ich aber sehr sehr traurig und ich weiß
dass das jetzt jeder machen wir dann hab
ich vor einiger zeit dieses bild hier
bei instagram gepostet wo ich draußen
lag und ist was schönes wetter und dann
habe ich einst elfi gemacht haben so
getan hat sich am schlafen allerdings
naja lorenz mag ich fand es nicht so
cool hast du das gemacht hat er hat
geschrieben fake du schläfst gar nicht
wissen alter wollte am abend ich jetzt
denke ich schon wieder alle das ist mein
placement aber es ist einfach nicht ich
glaube sogar diesen abgelaufen jetzt mal
ohne spaß
wie lange sind mauern sidebar die sind
in meiner wohnung seit circa einem
halben jahr und ich habe hier auch
letztes bei der klausur gegessen haben
irgendwie total hart und komisch
gefleckt ein bisschen wild machen wir
weiter
ich habe etwas sehr kluges auf twitter
geschrieben mal wieder sondern richtig
dickes ding so ich hasse unsere
gesellschaft in zukunft richtig falsch
oder gut schlecht meine stimmt ja auch
in einer gewissen form nur weil der also
ich mag es gar nicht wenn irgendjemand
irgendwen anders sagen
die musik ist scheiße wie du hörst es
gibt halt nur verschiedene geschmäcker
wismar mit stecker überhaupt nicht mein
geschmack
lecker lecker lecker essen bekommen sagt
der krieg hat uns auch mal was zu essen
jedenfalls hat dann einen twitter user
namens kariben darüber geschrieben als
man halte auch ich verstehe das nicht
die kann eine rechtschreibung so
schlecht sein halt's maul heißt es dann
in der langform hans haller maul halten
maul halten egal ich habe es auf jeden
fall stark ich so
hast du unsere gesellschaft in bezug auf
richtig falsch oder gut und schlecht
halt's maul eventuell ein oder andere
mitbekommen ich war beim let's play
pokal mit mit mit diana mit lukas mit
hardy mit oliver pocher und unseren
partnern leuten noch und bin als zweiter
rausgeflogen relativ schnell am anfang
und dann habe ich ein bild davon
gepostet und dann meinte der user eric
darunter luca du kannst dich pokern du
bist so schlecht wie ein affe duo wurde
bullock finde das immer richtig süß wie
er mit mir umgeht so auf twitter und
auch in den instagram kommentaren und
jade und kaiser schreibt ich komme nicht
darauf klar wie gespielt das ist tut mir
ja leid aber es sieht einfach extremste
schauspieler daraus diese aggressivität
ich hab dich lieb lieb conny aber das
ist irgendwie creed ii
das ist jetzt ich weiß es ist kein
richtiger böse oder nummer kommentar das
ist halt kritik und natürlich kann ich
nachvollziehen wenn irgendjemand meint
so höre dass ich geschauspielert oder so
aber es ist halt wirklich so dass das
sich zurzeit irgendwie wirklich so viel
aggressivität in mir drin habe und mich
so schnell über kleine dinge auf regel
also das war unter seinem video wo ich
halt in so ein spiel gespielt hatte
sollen so in rage spielt mal wieder aber
es ist definitiv nicht geschauspielert
also es ist nicht so dass nicht wirklich
so aufnehme richtig ausrasten und dann
bin ich so wie drücke ich auch erst
stoppt button und dann bin ich auf
einmal wieder ganz ruhig also so ist es
halt wirklich nicht sondern ich weiß
nicht auch wenn ich so privat alleine
zog oder mit freunden oder so da gehen
schon die ein oder anderen controller
einfach kaputt weil wir so rumschreien
also ich weiß nicht ich bin einfach so
aggressiv bei solchen spielen ich habe
halt solche spieler nur für solche
spiele noch vorher noch nie auf youtube
hochgeladen in der form deswegen kommt
es eventuell einige so voll dass die
mich jetzt nicht so krass kennen aber
eigentlich nichts davon dass die
schauspieler das wollte ich nur mal kurz
klar schneller kann hey luca wollte dich
fragen ob du vielleicht mal cookie
clicker let's play kann es wäre cool ich
habe das gesucht hat und bei allen
upgrades maximal dann kommt lukas rupp
genau darunter kann ich deine mutter
auch let's play und dann antwortet
wieder der serkan nähe ich nimm deine
auseinander
ich weiß nicht wie kommt man auf so wir
sind schon mal zehn minuten der aufnahme
hier langsam wieder durch hasse die
nächsten 3 kommentare sind alle vor
twitter weil ich auf twitter in letzter
zeit ein mega aktiv bin und zwar habe
ich da getan hat orange orange orange
diese rolle mit den fruchtigen und
schönsten smiley man könnte sagen
wiesmann smiley der woche orange orange
orange ich bin wirklich der orange
smiley von den ganzen images im iphone
oder was weiß ich wo in welchem
smartphone ist der allerschönste der ist
so knallig und ich liebe orange und alle
vom platz und dann kommt eine antwort
von von leon roger der nächsten kurve
story ist wahr dass der finne lallukka
dann habe ich wieder sowas people's
gepostet irgendwie sowas in die richtung
wie ja lasst euch nicht unterkriegen
oder irgendwann zum scheiß herrtutorial
sami slimani dingen etwa und dann
schreibt der max 54 einfach so kalt sein
scheiß maulkorb kraft also ich gehe also
total was nicht und dann einfach halt
deinen scheiß baulmann sei einfach ruhig
vor allem das allerdings ist das sehe
ich gerade erst da hat er sich selber
dann aber berichtigt eine minute danach
und zwar sorry wegen dem kommentar das
ist die philosophie hinter hat einfach
so schnell noch vor da steht jemand auf
der bühne und hält eine rede und sagte
ja lasst euch nicht unterkriegen dann
steht einmal publikum
halt's maul sorry wegen dem konzert
total hin
ich weiß nicht was ich davon halten soll
das ist eigentlich lacht also rüber aber
eigentlich müsste man dürfte man darüber
nicht lachen
damit ist arminia ja letztens im
dfb-pokal leider rausgeflogen in
wolfsburg kann ich meine ich bin stolz
auf meine truppe dass ich es überhaupt
so weit geschafft haben und dann habe
ich halt auch gehör die die arminia-fans
die singen noch immer egal ob sieg
niederlage oder sonstwas leidenschaft
kennt keine liga hashtag dsc gegen
wolfsburg dann hat die sattel spinne
drunter kommentiert du stinkst wir alle
stinken mike patton der letzte kommentar
unter dem video achtung brutales spiel
dieses spiel wohl gedärme rausgezogen
wurden und in zeichentrick unklar
da habe ich in die tiefe geschrieben 18
brutales spiel und dann schreibt nik hd
darunter nur bei konkreter sonne pussy
ist fünf daumen hoch
auch freunde das war es mit diesem video
ich hoffe euch hat gefallen mir hat es
auf jeden fall gefallen ich hatte wieder
den spaß meines lebens wenn ihr
irgendwelche böse kommentare unter
irgendwelchen videos von mir sieht oder
irgendwas witziges werberates können
wenn mir das ja zitieren oder so einen
fuß in die kommentare hier schreiben und
an screenshot oder verlinken oder
jedenfalls will ich mich sehr über eine
bewertung freuen weil das immer extrem
viel arbeit ist das ganze einerseits
rauszusuchen und auch noch zu bearbeiten
deswegen würde ich sagen mauern vor
allem wenn ihr in den vierten tag herr
hier sind nur drei bussen das vierte
rennen den vierten teil von böse
kommentare beantworten wollt dann neigt
das video und bei 10.000 likes mache ich
im stanton neues nein mache ich nicht